on passe à la chronique de l'écho comme
chaque jeudi clair qu'en billet bonsoir
claire bonsoir Le Salon du livre de
Paris approche il débutera du 22 mars
jusqu'au 25 un salon attendu par de
nombreux acteurs du secteur notamment
d'un point de vue commercial alors
justement est-ce que ce marché se porte
bien le numérique prend-il départ de
marché au livre physique pourquoi alors
que le prix du livre est unique la santé
économique des points de vente est si
différente pour en parler nous recevons
Gilles font la Deva bonjour directeur de
la maison d'édition indépendante
inoctaveau
alors vous tenez un stand de tous les
deux ans au salon cette année donc vous
allez vous n'avez pas de stand mais vous
allez vous y rendre pour
le côté commercial qu'est-ce que vous
allez y faire concrètement
bien prendre des contacts principalement
pour envisager des sessions de droits
soit en traduction à l'internationale
soit à l'audiovisuel donc dans un
optique plus hexagonale ça sort un peu
finalement du secteur du livre partir
dans le cinéma
doit ses auteurs c'est à dire que le
marché du livre est en ce qu'il est
nous avons quand même en charge du
rétribu le travail de nos auteurs et
donc nous examinons toutes les pistes
qui nous permet de le faire et les
auteurs le demandent d'ailleurs
peut-être de plus en plus il y en a
beaucoup qui ont rêvent
mais est-ce que ça fait partie des
exigences aussi quand on signe avec un
éditeur
écoutez en ce qui me concerne non alors
par contre ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que le contrat d'édition
ne comprend jamais les droits
audiovisuels c'est à ceci font toujours
de l'objet d'un contrat par et parfois
d'ailleurs bon à un auteur peut juger
que son éditeur n'est pas le mieux à
même de le défendre sur le plan de
l'audiovisuel et confier les parties du
choix des auteurs au moment de signer
avec un éditeur et regarde un petit peu
éventuellement puisque beaucoup en rêve
si un jour ils pourront voir leur livre
adaptés en série au cinéma alors ce
salon c'est un peu donc une référence
quand même dans le milieu et ce qu'il
est accessible à tous même aux petits
alors il existe effectivement des
formules
pour mais qui sont généralement réservés
aux primo exposants c'est-à-dire aux
gens qui explosent pour la première fois
donc
ces stands sont effectivement très
abordables mais malheureusement on en
profite qu'une fois
tous les deux ans c'est parfait il y a
quelques années mais maintenant je dois
donc la rentabilité n'est pas toujours
n'est pas toujours là c'est ça quand on
quand on dit un stand non il faut pas
venir à Paris surtout pas dans le but de
vendre des livres et de tirer un profit
parce que c'est une grosse vitrine une
vitrine très chère qui va vous réclamer
énormément d'investissements en temps et
d'investissement humain
et les ventes sont pendant le salon bon
si elle couvre les frais de bouche
c'est déjà pas si mal c'est un pari sur
l'avenir en fait voilà c'est un pari sur
l'avenir c'est le l'occasion de de se
faire connaître d'un public qu'on n'a
pas toujours l'occasion de toucher c'est
aussi le moyen de
bon d'offrir une reconnaissance à nos
auteurs qui généralement sont toujours
contents de signer à Paris même s'il
trouve parfois que les fils d'attente
devant notre stands sont pas aussi
importantes
que devant mon frère plus connu et
maintenant 10 ans c'est bien ça 2003 oui
donc nous venons de fêter notre dixième
anniversaire donc on commence se porte
votre maison d'édition est-ce que elle a
connu des difficultés ces temps-ci ou
finalement est-ce qu'au fil des années
vous avez réussi à monter monter et bien
en tout cas les trois derniers exercices
nous avons un chiffre d'affaires qui est
une diffusion qui est en expansion
donc on n'a pas de raison de faire trop
la grimace et de plus on voit bien et
dans les salons et auprès des libraires
que on commence à nous prendre au
sérieux à nous accueillir
on peut noter quand même que vous éditez
aussi des des écrivains du département
des Yvelines bien sûr oui oui
alors
nous n'avons pas raté un seul salon de
Rambouillet depuis
ce qui m'ont depuis la création du salon
donc forcément on a fait la connaissance
d'un certain nombre de personnes
qui font le
paysage littéraire des Yvelines et on a
rencontré des auteurs qui sont à la fois
extrêmement talentueux attachants comme
Hélène Guillemin dont nous avons publié
le premier roman
je vous laisse présenter l'ouvrage vous
êtes venu avec alors
un petit peu voilà peut-être des
Louboutins mais je ne l'affirmerai pas
et un roman extrêmement dense fiévreux
et d'une écriture remarquable surtout
pour une si jeune femme
en tout cas pour pour vous donc vous
avez bien bien évolué ces dernières
années mais ces deux trois
deux trois dernières années pardon et
vous connaissez quand même des
rentabilités plus faibles
alors le
on doit faire face effectivement à des
des frais de distribution et de
diffusion qui ne vont pas en s'améliorer
le
maintenant les libraires sont souvent
au-dessus de 30 % à 35 voire 40 pour les
grosses enseignes ce qu'on appelle les
librairies de premier niveau
un diffuseur va vous coûter entre 15 et
22%
donc vous imaginez qu'il reste pas grand
chose pour rémunérer l'éditeur son
équipe et l'auteur qui quand même un
temps un peu de
considération sonante et trébuchante
pour son travail
donc effectivement
les marges de réduites les marches se
réduisent et
on a à peu près maintenant on a connu
une période de réduction des coûts qui
arrivent à son terme parce que on a fait
à peu près tout ce qu'on pouvait faire
en termes de rationalisation de à la
fois de la fabrication et de
l'impression
au niveau de l'impression du coup c'est
des fois l'autre délocalisé
je travaille encore avec des sapiens
français j'en trouve mais c'est vrai
qu'ils seront rares et bon
les prix qui me concentrent
sont extrêmement amicaux et je doute que
ces enrichissent beaucoup plus que moi
mais on arrive encore à travailler en
français mais c'est vrai que le système
est un peu sur
le fil rouge j'ai tendu à son rompre et
on est tous un peu
se demander ce que l'avenir nous réserve
alors nous sommes allés à la rencontre
de Marie-Christine roux qui est chargée
d'études au motif l'Observatoire du
livre d'Île-de-France on a sélectionné
quelques extraits pour cette chronique
je vous propose d'écouter le premier qui
porte sur le constat actuel du marché
en fait est à peu près stable on a des
variations selon les sources qui sont
voilà à quelques
0,x points de hausse ou de baisse donc
on constate quand même que chiffre
d'affaires et à peu près stable la
difficulté c'est qu'en fait le marché
Seignette parce que le nombre d'acteurs
augmentent malgré tout le nombre de
maisons d'édition
ne baisse pas le nombre de de titres
augmentent toujours donc du coup même si
le chiffre d'affaires global est
synonyme reste la première industrie
culturelle en France je pense qu'il faut
vraiment
se rappeler le vent la musique et devant
le cinéma
pour chacun des acteurs en fait on
constate de vraies difficultés
de vrais guides difficultés donc ce que
nous indique Marie-Christine roux c'est
finalement que le chiffre d'affaires ne
baisse pas forcément mais qu'il y a une
multiplication d'acteurs dans le milieu
est-ce que vous le ressentez est-ce
qu'il y a beaucoup de concurrence oui
c'est un milieu je parlerai pas de
concurrence parce que il faut pas
oublier quand même que
cette multitude des acteurs c'est ce qui
garantit
naturel la diversité de l'offre et que
ça c'est très important parce que
nos maisons travaillent aussi un peu
comme comme des laboratoires
c'est à dire que
je dirais pas que nous testons esquiver
demain parce que d'abord ce sont des
écrivains d'aujourd'hui et les livres
qui publient chez nous
ne pourraient parfaitement sortir sous
l'enseignement de maison mais
nous avons la taille de ce qui nous
permet de d'être un peu plus audacieux
un peu moins frileux de
doser finalement aborder d'autres
d'autres types d'auteurs et donc c'est
le fait c'est la même chose dans les
disques si on supprime tous les
producteurs indépendants et qu'on laisse
juste trois ou quatre grands labels on
voit bien que la création de musicale en
sortira extrêmement appauvri je pense
que le s'il y a autant de petits acteurs
dans l'édition c'est avant tout un pari
culturel et puis surtout une enfin je
veux dire une passion pour la culture
une passion pour pour l'écrit et le cas
dans les maisons d'édition c'est le cas
aussi dans au niveau de la distribution
finalement comment vous fonctionnez
est-ce que vous passez quand même par
des gros enseignes ou
alors nous avons
distributeur national qui travaille avec
principalement avec la librairie
traditionnelle c'est à dire les
librairies de ce qu'on appelle de
premier niveau et de deuxième niveau
donc
la distinction est un peu technique on
va pas
mais disons que les livrets le premier
niveau c'est 500 premières et qu'ensuite
vous avez un réseau encore assez dense
probablement grâce à la langue de
libraire qui sont des libraires soit
spécialisés soit de plus petite taille
avec lesquels nous travaillons
avec des
des des grands des grands groupes alors
assez peu parce que le la grande
distribution est quelque chose
d'extrêmement contraignant bon d'abord
en termes de production c'est à dire que
si vous voulez travailler avec Auchan il
faut
tirer au moins 5000 exemplaires bon si
vous travaillez tout de même avec la
Fnac et cultura la Fnac culturelleclerc
mais parce que on peut on peut se sont
encore des enseignes avec lesquels on
peut avoir un dialogue de type culturel
et non pas vendre des livres comme comme
on vend des secs ou des patates donc
à ce moment-là on n'a pas besoin de
il y a encore des rapports humains et
littéraires qui jouent et qui reste et
puis dans l'espace culturels Leclerc
chez Cultura il y a des à la FNAC il y a
des libraires alors il y a des gens qui
ont une formation on parle de libraire
donc je pense que ça serait 40% de votre
distribution on s'est rendu dans une
petite librairie indépendante à
Fontenay-le-Fleury et on a cherché à
savoir finalement comment elle pouvait
gagner en concurrence par rapport aux
grands enseignants on regarde son image
c'est dans cette petite ruelle de
Fontenay-le-Fleury que Christine a
installé sa librairie il y a maintenant
deux ans elle a réaménagé cet ancien
corps de ferme et y accueille habitué et
Jean de passage j'ai gardé donc les
pierres apparentes les boiseries
ça permet
un endroit convivial où les gens peuvent
venir lire ils peuvent venir lire sur
place des livres qui sont mis à
disposition qui sont sélectionnés à
travers le cercle littéraire ce cercle
littéraire est ouvert à tous les
passionnés de lecture et permet de
découvrir des ouvrages et d'en discuter
ensemble plus qu'une boutique un lieu de
rencontre où certains ne viennent que
pour prendre un café et discuter de leur
dernière lecture une librairie à son
lieu des grandes surfaces et c'est ce
côté qui plaît aux clients je regarde
les livres qu'elle a les jeux et
puis je prends des bonbons quand il y en
a on ne se sent pas des clients on se
sent des
des voisins des gens qui font partie de
la maison des bons il y a une
convivialité un peu exceptionnelle une
convivialité qui n'empêche pas les
difficultés économiques de cette
librairie indépendante nous avons des
marches beaucoup plus faibles qui sont
définies par nos fournisseurs
des grandes structures comme la Fnac ou
Amazon on démarche de 50% en ayant les
mêmes fournisseurs que nous et nos
marches nous se situent plus vers les
vins à 30%. son chiffre d'affaires est
donc assez faible mais selon Christine
c'est l'ensemble du secteur qui est
touché le best-seller de l'année
dernière la Ligue de mes envies qui est
à 16 euros le prix moyen fortement
diminué à savoir que précédemment donc
l'année d'avant les livres se situaient
entre
20-22 euros une baisse qui n'a cependant
pas relancé les ventes pour pallier à
ces difficultés financières Christine
vont également des jouets et des bijoux
dans l'avenir et l'envisage de partager
son local avec d'autres petites sociétés
où chacun aura sa plage horaire
alors donc elle connaît évidemment
quelques difficultés dans dans d'autres
difficultés on parle aussi beaucoup du
numérique et de la fin du papier qui
pourrait un peu bloquer le développement
du marché est-ce que pour vous c'est une
réalité
je ne crois pas du tout à la fin du
papier
maintenant le numérique est une réalité
puisque on voit bien que
on en distribue en distribue des
tablettes dans les écoles
nos enfants sont vivent à l'air
numérique donc le numérique c'est
effectivement une réalité dire que ça va
tuer le papier je pense que ça n'est pas
vrai parce que le papier ça reste quand
même
je dirais le meilleur support quand on a
affaire de la littérature donc les deux
supports vont exister justement les deux
supports
nous éditons en numérique nous avons
quelques résultats extrêmement modeste
pour l'instant sur le plan financier
mais nous nous éditons de ce livre est
disponible en numérique et
ça reste un chiffre d'affaires
finalement
je ne pense pas que ce soit une vraie
menace pour le livre papier
je crois plutôt que
on devrait assister à l'apparition donc
de création qui sont des créations
différentes qui seront adaptées au
support parce que pour l'instant le
texte n'est pas quelque chose qui
exploite les possibilités
rouges justement de du profil et assez
d'accord avec vous elle pense finalement
que le numérique n'est pas le problème
on écoute ces sonores
et l'inversion numérique
des livres papier
ce sont plutôt des ventes sur Internet
qui
qui touche évidemment les points de
vente et c'est là qu'il a la vraie
difficulté comme les derniers événements
et notamment Virgin même si les Virgin
n'est pas que vendeur de livres
de ces difficultés finalement ce qu'elle
souligne c'est que ce sont plutôt les
ventes sur le net qui qui plombe un peu
le marché est-ce que c'est quelque chose
que vous ressentez vous aussi l'arrivée
effectivement des gros distributeurs
comme Amazon créer des distorsions
concurrence
tout simplement parce que Amazon n'a pas
du tout les mêmes charges il n'obéit pas
du tout la même législation que calibrer
qui a pignon sur rue donc notamment ils
peuvent par exemple offrir les les frais
de port ce qui n'est pas possible pour
en matière fiscale et
légales
Amazon crée effectivement une grosse
dissertation de concurrence maintenant
ce qu'il faut bien voir c'est que
Amazon c'est une grosse machine une
grosse locomotive qui ne tire que les
wagons de tête donc
peut-être aussi qui faudrait que
les libraires se recentre sur le conseil
la découverte et
la littérature de qualité chose qu'on
trouvera jamais chez Amazon on va quand
même nuancer les ventes pour l'instant
sur le net ne représentent que 9%
d'après le motif donc ça reste tout de
même encore assez faible il faut juste
éviter donc ça s'accélère peut-être
moi c'est le souhait que je forme parce
que
je trouve que une librairie est un bien
bel endroit et je voudrais qu'il en
reste de si possible un peu partout dans
ce pays encore cette chronique sur le
marché du livre à présent on va
découvrir le lancement de nouvelles
bornes c'est dans les médiathèques de
Saint-Quentin que ça se passe exactement
donc un projet colossal et coûteux
financé par la communauté
d'agglomération des nouvelles bornes
mises en place donc dans les
médiathèques pour emprunter soi-même ses
livres
désormais le prêt de documents se fait
en self-service à la médiathèque Jacques
Brel de Magny-les-Hameaux qui a rouvert
le 27 février après un mois de travaux
ces travaux de modernisation
s'inscrivent dans un projet global de
950000 euros financés à 70% par l'État
et la région et qui concernera tout le
réseau de médiathèques saint-continoises
l'équipe de la médiathèque a encoder les
23000 documents que nous avons au fond
c'est à dire que nous avons apposé sur
chaque document de la médiathèque une
étiquette
RFID c'est une étiquette
d'identification par radiofréquence qui
permet en fait de d'automatiser les
transactions au sein de la médiathèque
Jacques Brel les 2500 adhérents peuvent
désormais emprunter livres CD et DVD de
manière autonome il tâtonne encore sous
l'oeil bienveillant des médiathèques
c'est ma première fois donc j'ai un peu
galéré pour pour la carte d'adhérent
mais
après j'ai eu les explications de la
bibliothécaire donc ça c'est bien passé
maintenant c'est dommage si du coup il y
a moins de bibliothécaires au niveau
contact le contact sera paradoxalement
renforcé l'automatisation permet aux
quatre médiathèques restés en poste de
se consacrer davantage à leur cœur de
métier la médiation culturelle nous
sommes affranchis de tout ce qui était
matérialisation en fait tout ce qui
était
transaction de documents des antivolages
des documents pour justement
pouvoir mieux renseigner pouvoir être
présent
d'accompagner de répondre
aux sollicitations des adhérents donc
c'est c'est l'avantage de cette
automatisation l'autre nouveauté et la
mise en place d'une boîte de retour
automatique 24 heures sur 24 à
l'extérieur dont le design ressemble à
un distributeur de billets elle devrait
être opérationnelle en septembre quand
la totalité des médiathèques du réseau
sera uniformisée par le système de puces
la médiathèque Anatole France de trappes
et la prochaine à ce moderniser elle
sera fermée au public du 2 au 29 avril
pour une réouverture le 30
donc quand on voit ce sujet on réalise
que que les communautés aident que les
collectivités pardon aide le secteur
alors est-ce que ce n'est vrai que pour
les bibliothèques les médiathèques ou
est-ce que ça touche finalement tout le
secteur du livre
non il existe une institution qui
s'appelle le centre national de livre
lequel a une politique d'aide à
l'édition
le principalement d'ailleurs au niveau
des traductions et également un peu de
donc des
projets éditoriaux disons à caractère
très particulier c'est à dire dans le la
rentabilité économique apparaîtront
vraiment trop incertaine mais qui
présente un intérêt sur le plan
littéraire éthologique ou autre donc
on peut effectivement réclamer des
subventions
je le fais très peu parce que je me dis
que ceux qui me subventionne finalement
le mieux sont encore les lecteurs et
ceux qui nous font la confiance
d'acheter nos livres
voilà et on les espère nombreux merci à
vous on termine cette chronique de
l'Echo à présent après ce point sur le
marché du livre avec l'ouverture du
Salon du livre Le 22 on s'intéresse
maintenant aux infos en plus oui alors
vous avez parlé il y a quelques temps du
projet d'extension du Magasin Ikea à
Plaisir la commission départementale
d'aménagement commercial devait trancher
mardi à cause des intempéries de
nombreux membres de la commission n'ont
pu être présent
l'examen est donc reporté au 20 mars et
on rappelle que le groupe souhaitait
agrandir de 10 000 mètres carrés son
magasin des nouvelles de Renault à
présent avec ce mode de cette mode de
toute électrique oui puisque c'est la
sortie de la Zoé la nouvelle voiture
électrique de Renault des portes
ouvertes sont organisées à partir
d'aujourd'hui et jusque ce week-end dans
de nombreuses concessions pour l'essayer
cette voiture donc est uniquement
produite à l'usine de Flins pour
l'instant de 60 à 80 Zoé sortiraient
tous les jours de l'usine merci Claire à
jeudi prochain pour une nouvelle
chronique de l'écho vont s'intéresser à
présent aux droits de vote des étrangers
alors que le gouvernement semble avoir
fait marcher derrière